When we observe
the physical world,
we find a random
fluctuations everywhere.
We can generate
truly random numbers
by measuring random
fluctuations known as noise.
When we measure this
noise, known a sampling,
we can obtain numbers.
For example, if we measure
the electric current
of TV static over time, we
will generate a truly random
sequence.
We can visualize
this random sequence
by drawing a path
that changes direction
according to each number,
known as a random walk.
Notice the lack of
pattern at all scales.
At each point in the
sequence, the next move
is always unpredictable.
Random processes are said
to be non-deterministic,
since they're impossible
to determine in advance.
Machines on the other
hand, are deterministic.
Their operation
predictable and repeatable.
In 1946, John von
Neumann was involved
in running computations for the
military, specifically involved
in the design of
the hydrogen bomb.
Using a computer
called the ENIAC,
he planned to
repeatedly calculate
approximations of the processes
involved in nuclear fission.
However, this required
quick access to randomly
generated numbers that
could be repeated if needed.
However, the ENIAC had very
limited internal memory.
Storing long random
sequences was not possible.
So Neumann developed
an algorithm
to mechanically simulate the
scrambling aspect of randomness
as follows.
First, select a truly random
number, called the seed.
This number comes from
the measurement of noise,
or the current time
in milliseconds.
Next, this seed is provided as
input to a simple calculation.
Multiply this seed by itself.
And then output the
middle of this result.
Then you use this
output as the next seed
and repeat the process
as many times as needed.
This is known as the
middle-squares method,
and is just the first in a long
line of pseudo random number
generators.
The randomness of
the sequence is
dependent on the randomness
of the initial seed only.
Same seed, same sequence.
So what are the differences
between a randomly generated
versus pseudorandomly
generated sequence?
Let's represent each
sequence as a random walk.
They seem similar until
we speed things up.
The pseudorandom sequence
must eventually repeat.
This occurs when the
algorithm reaches
a seed it has previously
used, and the cycle repeats.
The lengths, before a
pseudorandom sequence repeats,
is called the period.
The period is strictly
limited by the length
of the initial seed.
For example, if we
use a two digit seed,
then an algorithm can
produce at most 100 numbers
before reusing a seed
and repeating the cycle.
A three digit seed can
expand past 1,000 numbers
before repeating its cycle.
And a four digit seed can
expand past 10,000 numbers
before repeating.
Though if we use a
seed large enough,
the sequence can expand
into trillions and trillions
of digits before repeating,
though the key difference
is important.
When you generate
numbers pseudorandomly,
there are many sequences,
which cannot occur.
For example, Alice generates
a truly random sequence
of 20 shifts.
It's equivalent to
a uniform selection
from the stack of all
possible sequences of shifts.
This stack contains
26 to the power
20 pages, which is
astronomical in size.
If we stood at the bottom
and shined a light upwards,
a person at the
top would not see
the light for around
200 million years.
Compare this to Alice generating
a 20 digit pseudorandom
sequence using a four
digit random seed.
Now this is equivalent
to a uniform selection
from 10,000 possible
initial seeds.
Meaning, she can only generate
10,000 different sequences,
which is a vanishingly
small fraction
of all possible sequences.
When we move from random
to pseudorandom shifts,
we shrink the key space into a
much, much smaller seed space.
So for a pseudorandom
sequence to be
indistinguishable from a
randomly generated sequence,
it must be impractical for
a computer to try all seeds
and look for a match.
This leads to an important
distinction in computer science
between what is
possible, versus what
is possible in a
reasonable amount of time.
We use the same logic
when we buy a bike lock.
We know that anybody can simply
try all possible combinations
until they find a
match and it opens.
But it would take
them days to do so.
So for eight hours.
We assume it's practically safe.
With pseudorandom
generators, the security
increases as the length
of the seed increases.
If the most powerful computer
would take hundreds of years
to run through all
seeds, then we safely
can assume it's practically
secure, instead of perfectly
secure.
As computers get
faster, the seed size
must increase accordingly.
Pseudorandomness
frees Alice and Bob
from having to share
their entire random shift
sequence in advance.
Instead, they share a
relatively short random seed,
and expand it into the same
random looking sequence
when needed.
But what happens
if they can never
meet to share this random seed?